- Can I keep my own accent?
- Hmm, Okay, I like how I
get to make these decisions.
- Founder.
(woman in dark dress screams)
(gunshot)
(glass breaks)
(gunshots)
- God damn it!
Emily!
- I don't know what I'm doing!
(fire)
(lighthearted music)
- (Announcer) And today's video is called.
We all go a little mad sometimes.
- That's it?
- That's it.
(Andie laughs)
- Psycho?
- What's a--
- It's Psycho!
- What?
- Oh wow
- Nice job!
- That's great!
- We all go a little mad sometimes.
(ominous music)
(laughs)
(Mark coughs)
- Hey, check this out.
(Mark laughs)
I found the Ass End!
- So I feel like someone's been severed,
and they found like the--
- Yeah.
- They found the ass?
- Yeah, the ass end
- What's one of the old--
- Centipede movie.
- It's gotta be something that's funny.
It's gotta be, I don't know.
- Yeah.
- Tremors!
(Andie laughs)
- I've never seen that.
- Hey!
Hey, check this out!
(footsteps on sand)
I found the ass end!
- Don't fuck with Chuck.
- With The Chuck.
- Don't fuck with the Chuck (laughs).
Damn it!
- [Mark] I feel like that makes--
- Someone named Chuck.
- Oh.
Isn't that like Saw, or
something like one of those.
- What's the creepy Chucky,
- Oh yeah
- Oh, Child's Play.
Chucky.
- Chucky.
- Charles Play Three (laughs).
- Okay, there you go.
- She's like, you had three up for so long
(Andie laughs)
Charles Play Fingers?
I don't understand what you're--
- Don't fuck with the Chuck.
(evil laughter)
What do you want?
- [Angie] ooh.
to see what your insides look like.
Oh, I think I know this.
Scream?
- (the women) Aye!
- Yeah!
Oh wow.
- Good job.
- What do you want?
- To see what your insides look like.
(terrifying music)
- By the way, I would have voted for Obama
for a third term if could.
- Get out!
- Best president in my lifetime.
Hands down.
- Get out.
- Get out (laughs)
- Sorry to call you out, I was
just really excited (laughs).
- Very good!
I thought you were just saying, "get out."
(laughter)
- You thought I was,
yeah dude, went with it.
- Get out man, get out.
(laughter)
By the way, I would have voted for Obama
for a third term if I could.
Best president in my lifetime, hands down.
I'm a TS-Motherfucking-A.
We handle shit.
That's what we do.
Consider this situation, fucking handled.
Oh.
Get out!
- [Camerawoman] Yeah!
- Oh!
- Trixie!
- Man!
- I haven't seen it.
- You haven't seen it.
- No, I really need to.
- Very high rating on Rotten Tomato.
- [Andie] Yeah, it's so good.
- I'm TS
motherfucking A.
We handle shit.
That's what we do.
(white noise)
Consider this situation,
fucking handled.
- I'm your number one fan.
(Samara nervously laughs)
- The fan?
(sucks in breath) Misery!
Is it? Whoa.
- Oh my god, what did you do, study?
- Yeah--
- Did you study?
- Six years.
(Andie laughs)
Six years all leading up to this moment.
Finally.
- I'm your number one fan.
- Darling.
Light of my life.
I'm not gonna hurt ya.
You didn't let me finish my sentence.
I said, I'm not gonna hurt ya.
I'm just gonna bash your brains in.
- Whoa.
(inquisitive music)
Oh, the Shining!
- Oh!
The Shining!
- Oh my gosh!
- How did we not think of that?
- Aw!
And I already had that--
- That's when you have the bag,
and he's like, "give me
the bag, give me the bag."
(Samara groans)
- Of course!
- We all suck, except I got
all the others right, so.
- Darling.
(girl breathes frantically)
Light of my life.
I'm not gonna hurt ya.
You didn't let me finish my sentence.
I said, I'm not gonna hurt ya.
I'm just gonna bash your brains in
- Yes, I did it.
I killed Yvette.
I hated her so much,
it,
it.
(Samara and Mark laughs)
- Flames (laughs).
- What?
- I killed a vet? I killed Yvette?
- Yvette, like a name.
- Oh, Yvette, okay.
- On the side of my face.
Breathing.
(Mark laughs)
Breathless,
heaping breaths,
heaping.
- Oh, Clueless, Clue!
- [All three] Clue!
- Clue.
(Samara Claps)
- Andie.
- Really good!
- I am so impressed with myself
- You got that completely on your own.
I hated her
so...
much.
It, it, flames, flames,
flames, on the side of my face.
- Oh.
You got a letter?
I got ran over, Helen
gets her hair chopped off,
and Julie gets a body in her trunk,
and you get a letter?
That's balanced.
- [Andie] What the heck?
- I could have done that better (laughs),
but that's what it says.
- [Andie] Okay?
Hints?
- [Camerawoman] It's a long title.
- Okay.
- I know what you did last summer?
- [Camerawoman] There you go!
- Whoa.
- Oh my gosh.
- (camerawoman cheers)
- Did you give him the answers before?
- Oh, you got a letter?
I got run over.
Helen gets her hair chopped off,
Julie gets a body in a
trunk, and you get a letter?
That's balanced.
- Okay, okay.
- But Mark's a clear winner.
- I didn't wanna say it, well
I would have if you didn't.
- [Camerawoman] You're the best person
that we've had play this game.
(Samara gasps)
- Oh my god.
- Do not let it go to your head.
- [Camerawoman] You also were pretty good.
- We wanted to get married.
- So it's my fucking fault,
- No, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, shhh.
- Are you fucking serious?!
(dramatic music)
(gentle beats)